[Musique]
de retour au québec avec votre groupe la
compagnie créole est un effort d'amour
entre vous et je sais pas comment vous
l'expliquez selon d'amour là on
n'explique pas maintenant nous sommes
ravis parce que ça fait 35 ans que les
au québec et chaque fois qu'on a
l'opportunité de le faire nous sommes
quand même très excité à l'idée de
revenir dans votre nos amis québécois
[Musique]
sacha
a débuté par un téléthon en 85 et depuis
on laisse tomber en amour a été l'étoile
ça dure et c'est super à une somme ravis
la compagnie créole bien des antilles
vous êtes né en martinique
josé de la guyane assure en guadeloupe
mais vous êtes tous rencontrés à paris
sous licence alors moi j'étais à paris
j'étais étudiant à paris 2008 apparaît
donc je sentais un petit peu comme ça
pour comme les comme les étudiants qui
font des petits jobs mais guy mais les
garçons se retrouvait souvent dans les
discothèques dans les boîtes de nuit
c'était le boeuf ensemble
et pas du tout de ma tête mais moi je
pensais pas du tout faire carrière dans
la chanson ekanga c'est grâce et athée
particulier comme histoire vos plus gros
succès ça fait rire les oiseaux vive le
douanier rousseau coni collet ont été
écrits par le tandem daniel vague arbres
et jeudi fiquet français et jean kruger
québec quand même comment ça s'est passé
là encore vous offrent de tels grands
succès mais parce qu en fait daniel et
j'étais dix collaborateurs israël a fait
pas mal de chansons avant et même le
même la chanson de jean yves rousseau
c'était pas du tout
on sera là mais pas su donner aux flots
[Musique]
l'ania voulait d'abord 60 sur picasso et
il a eu des problèmes avec les droits
lésés endroits de cela et plus guère
j'en passe et il a vu un tableau très
coloré agouazi pourquoi tu serais pas un
saut sous maillot cela ça leur a donné
l'idée et cette chanson en fait il a été
créé parce que il a besoin d'aller
demander son comble pour la france pour
l'eurovision
donc on a besoin de cette chanson pour
la sélection elle n'a pas été retenu et
et en même temps c'était bien parce que
ça permet un hangar de sortir c'est bon
pour le moral
[Musique]
on trouvait ça nul ça je crois pas comme
tous ici mais c'est l'association
[Musique]
et l'album est sorti
d'ailleurs aux 60 et après est ce
premier album de platine
jeunes question disent je sais qu'à
chaque chanson est comme un enfant
préféré ce sont les coeurs
mais moi je dis bien santa maria des
voix de louper
et puis le noël bons baisers de fort de
france par ce concept une chanson peu
d'années l'a écrite quand j'ai expliqué
en fait qu'à noël quand j'avais
découvert en france qu'il ya des gens
qui restait seule
personne je ne comprenais pas pense que
chez nos anti à noël c'est un moment où
tout le monde se retrouve vous pouvez
aller chez quelqu'un faut être évité et
on dit à la télé on éteint la télé et on
chante ensemble et pas d'hésitation et
c'est une vérité en fait
[Musique]
oh
des musiciens accomplis ont tous plus de
70 ans alors au cours des prochains
jours va être dans le spectacle jesse
tendresse février 2023 grosse tournée au
québec comment vous vivez encore sur la
scène c'est sûr que bon je vais pas
danser comme avant
mais je suis dedans ça y est je ne
ferais pas mais le rythme de la paix ce
bond qui josé c'est vrai un petit peu
fatiguée parce que la famille n'est
qu'une telle opération mais pour le
moral on a besoin du public et quand on
est sur scène qui nous redonne la pêche
et ses chroniques
sur la vidéo de la chanson ma toute
première dégaine partie on voit une
jeune fille c'est votre fille oui
j'avoue et semble sinon qu'elle est
prête à prendre au gabon sans la
confiance et le réel avec nous et chez
lesquels avec nous sur scène
chanter avec sa fille tout à fait ce
n'était pas prévu lorsqu'elle était
toujours je ferai jamais ce métier est
trop de stress
donc elle a fait la bonne direction
comme l arrêté après la fin du droit et
va finalement et en faisant elle venait
en fait avec nous pour gagner un peu
d'argent et étudiantes et mais s'évade
habilleuse et je ferai jamais ce pays a
trop de stress et trop stressants mais
finalement elle a eu le virus aussi
comme moment et voilà et chantait son
mari c'est d'être aussi adorent caisse
aussi clémence bringtown cette entrevue
a été bonne pour le moral merci beaucoup
[Musique]